our progress may be made the Met remains
institutionally racist
[Music]
and this
is a reality
we simply can't ignore or equivocate on
rather
we must confront this truth and recommit
to eradication racism from the Met and
from every every other sector and aspect
of our society
when it comes to cleaning up the Met
I've promised to go and flinching in my
response in fact I want rest until we've
drained the poison of institutional
racism from the Met police and all our
communities have trust and confidence in
our place we owe this to all londres
and we owe this to Doreen
to Stewart and the rest of the Lawrence
Family not least
because the best way we can honor
Stephen's memory